Caddyshack is not a sports moving it
isn't Nick Notaro understands his Nick
on the phone line right now yeah great
point buy bagged on here you can't okay
there's no movie Caddyshack without the
golf
I understand out the sports is Nick
tutorial on the phone case on our friend
or the actor Nick Nick Nick we already
we're already you're already starting
this thing off sports movies how would
you what we're saying would you say
Caddyshack as a sports movie Nick
Caddyshack is not a sports movie enough
ok slapstick is that a sports movie even
slap shot slap shot sorry stop shot not
slapstick so yeah slap shot is that a
sports lab to grant Odie it's a sports
movie that's a comedy that's got hockey
in it oh my gosh it's a dark comedy but
it's about hockey Bryce it's about
hockey in the 70s which was very edgy
it's there I think it's just kind of so
that's what I'm saying is that
Caddyshack is not a sports movie slap
shot as a sports move more of a sports
yeah absolutely
what are you putting weirdy charming in
over there you disagree this
conversation just think it without golf
there's there's no movie Caddyshack
exactly Golf is really not even a sport
I mean it's really not a sport it's a
game come on now if you want to get if
you want to get technical I mean I enjoy
it they consider it sports but it's it's
more of a game because you don't have to
be a great athlete to play that game
so athletics and being able to be have
to be so if you're if you could place so
let me phrase this brother way so if you
are playing in a competition as an
overweight individual that means you're
not playing in a sport you're playing in
a game is that what you're saying I'm
saying that you don't have to be a great
athlete you could be a fat guy and be a
good athlete but what I'm saying is
that's really not a true test of being a
great athlete
because you could play pool doesn't mean
you I had a final played pool but he
wasn't a good athlete he played pool but
the game it's not really a sport you
don't got a run you don't got to jump
you got a catch you got a skill right
you can hit that ball you got a skill
with that iron it doesn't make you a
great athlete that's why it's deceiving
when they call it you know
it's great you can't consider golf a
real true sport
what about racing what about automobile
racing what about NASCAR what do you
think about that Nick that's another
that's another one that kind of baffles
me because it's it is a skill I don't
know how you consider it sports but it
is a skill okay look I don't look at I
don't know NASCAR's it's a select thing
I don't know I don't quite put it in
like you know watching sports
okay so Days of Thunder is a skill movie
yeah okay that's my category that's the
way I looked at fantastic I feel a lot
of people disagree with me oh yeah I'm
sure too how's life for you Nick you
good everything good in your neck of the
woods your family life is okay so we're
time and I mean I'm surviving this thing
you know I think a lot of us are but
it's bizarre like The Twilight Zone you
must miss me you must be missing
baseball like crazy - right now I'm at
you know I've caught up on a lot of old
games reminiscing thinking about it
makes you think about life a lot this
this time you know because it's like we
take everything for granted you know we
take you know and now this like kind of
like smacks you in the face and go why
what is this what is the new normal what
does that mean you know so now I get up
and I put on an old game and it brings
me back and I'm thinking a lot about my
life because I remember this a lot my
brother's like always reminiscing can
reminisce so now I got a time to
reminisce like today I turned on and
I'll be networking there it was 2003
Game three the Pedro Martinez Roger
Clemens I was at that game you know
great game you know I say
brings back a lot of great games for me
that I was at that I watched as a kid
but I'm missing it yeah I mean I'd like
it to come back but I don't know how you
play sports without fans yes don't
understand I don't really get that I
hear you Nick you better get used to it
that that's that's the one thing I
that's the one thing you better get used
to because you know the number of people
that keep asking me you know a sports
gonna come back or leagues gonna come
back you know or it's not gonna happen
and my answer is I think so yes and then
the answer is with fans and I'm like
that he could pretty much say for the
moment a hundred percent is not
happening you know so yeah no I
understand I accepted I mean I watch the
UFC fight a few weeks ago it was Tony
Ferguson engage he and it was it was
weird nobody in the crowd no audience I
mean I enjoyed it but it was right so I
guess you're gonna have to somehow train
your your head to you know I don't I
feel like maybe if they had like maybe
one fan at a stadium I got could
represent like the Yanks games represent
Yankee fans would like a bunch of
cutouts put one guy in the middle just
for some energy you know yes but they
probably they probably wouldn't go for
it you know well no you could you could
be I have to be careful because
certainly you'd be able to you know be
heard you know what I mean like easier
than before so you definitely the way
that your Twitter account normally would
work during a Yankee game I think you'd
have to be very careful during an actual
game if you're the only fan in the
stands
I could I could curb it a little bit I
don't have to really like you know I
could just be a cheerleader you know
what I mean yeah I could be like the
tension the tense man the tension you
know like if you put me in the dugout of
something like if I was in the Yankee
dugout I think I could actually inspire
them and I could you know the whole
world is offended by it
by having a point of view today you know
you know you're a little harsh I'm like
I'm not that harsh I just tell it like
it is I mean you know as well about
hearing these old broadcasts they're
great because
you hear oh you know it guys are like
normal they were natural they were
organic now don't white us seems as
confirming Munson when they won the
World Series like you think you want to
be a Yankee next next year I'm like bill
why you askin sermonette so you're
seeing old
you seen old Yankee games like that
that's sort of I would see that and Bill
White was asking you know was weird like
you saw Billy Martin after they won the
championship and he looks depressed not
depressed but he looks like relieved I
don't know like you he was so stressed
out from that year it wasn't like today
they're wearing goggles and sole kind of
manufactured guys were like more normal
back then the more it was a different
time you know oh sure I mean you're
seeing you're seeing in the last dance
Jordan look totally spent after winning
a championship you know he ones he wins
he wins three in a row and first one was
joy second one was overjoyed third one
was relief you know I got about four in
and it's so good and kind of brings you
back to the NBA before the Bulls like
conquered you had the Lakers of Celtics
and the bad boy Pistons thugs that they
were you kind of felt you know you
beginning you felt like happy for Jordan
we finally broke through and they beat
those bullies and then they swept the
Lakers and then you know I didn't even
realize the triangle came from there's a
guy named text of all people tanks like
created the tendon and then what he call
ran with it so Jackson can't remember so
Jackson was you know bohemian kind of a
real hippie guy but a smart play them to
rent Holtzman and he played on those
smart Nick teams so he was always like a
guy ahead of his time a man you kind of
hit on something Nick tutorial here in
the Rich Eisen show you kind of hit on
something you're Nick that you know for
Knicks fans to see a guy from the red
Holtzman Walt Clyde Frazier or Bill
Bradley Dave DeBusschere era coaching
Michael Jordan ripping out the next best
chances to win a championship since the
red Holtzman years heart and show it to
him pump and that was awful tough for me
to handle as it was happening and
and reliving it you're gonna see in
upcoming episodes man it's tough you
know Charles Smith still trying to make
a layup number of times that the Knicks
almost had this team and could not
Jordan returning from his hiatus
dropping 55 in the garden within a week
I mean that sort of stuff is tough to
relive Nick so beware it is it is but
then again you gotta kind of embrace
what the Knicks were then in the 90s the
Knicks were very entertaining
they were very likable you know lunch
pail team unfortunately they were facing
Michael Jordan who was a different
animal and Knicks fans and including
myself were frustrated watching him
because he became a different animal and
he was he was a stone blood cold killer
and you know something you'll never see
again I mean the closest probably was
Kobe I mean you know LeBron is not that
so you know he's just not that guy this
guy his Drive what he will you know
I mean it wasn't even all talent that's
what this thing kind of shows you that
he had the talent but the guy was a
killer on so many levels it's
interesting it's an interesting show it
really is because it you know there was
a you don't realize that was a real deep
kind of time you know I mean it was
basketball was even everything was more
interesting I don't know had edge you
know today that's the problem we don't
have any you know everything watered
down today everything's nice nice
everybody's hugging kissing I'm sick of
it you know I mean yeah you kind of feel
like you know I'm glad I'm glad that I
you know and so I've shown my son last
night was like wow wow you see that you
don't you don't know other things happen
before you existed way to pass it down
Nick it's Nick - Nick - Turo here on the
Rich Eisen show all right I want to give
you the floor and what do you texted me
about you text me last night you're like
hey I lost a friend and a lot of people
know who this friend is the former WWE
star may he rest in peace shad gaspard I
give you the floor and how you got to
know him and what you'd like to say
about him
yeah I just uh there's a guy that really
became a friend who really kind of
touched me as a person a great spirit I
met him at the wild card West gym which
is now it's hurtful Jim Pete Berg owns
it and also my friend walk crews will
kind of brought me down there my son
learned had a box there and I've heard
first met shad gaspard there it's kind
of a big bigger than life guy didn't
really know him and little by little you
know we became friends he was kind of a
big dreamer guy that had you know wanted
always to make everybody smile and he
was more than just a big you know guy he
was he was talented he was small he was
good active was in comedies he was
developing a wrestling pilot that I did
a reading for him more recently a couple
of months back I did a reading of a
little pilot I'm developing called band
of idiots who came over read a role for
me he was that kind of guy and then you
know he sacrificed his life to his son
on Sunday I guess got caught in a
Riptide and they told the life club to
take his son first and you know then
they they grabbed his son he pushed his
son to he lived for his kid he not only
was a great guy and a good friend but he
was a great dad
and then the Riptide hit him and in a
matter of seconds you know I hadn't
experienced 17 in Long Beach Long Island
I could barely swim accordin and
undertow and lifeguards luckily I
wouldn't be here but for him you know to
go down like that you know he was just
not he was he just thought of other
people first and you imagine you're
confronted with that most people might
panic and say help help help hey he had
expenses they saved my son and you know
now he's he's not here and it's just the
whole situation but he was just a
beautiful guy I mean you just question
like you know know what this life is
about I don't know and I just feel like
heartbroken about
him you know and his son you know I tell
you it really hit me hard hit my my son
hard and you know we're only passing
through man but he was a guy that passed
through my life and became a friend he
was on my podcast you know he turned me
upside down to kill my vertigo one day
picked me up like it mean he's a
mountain of a man and I I just can't I
can't get put my arms about that like
he's gone and watching the videos last
night I had of him I just wanted to pay
tribute to him I know a lot of people
are the rock Eden Dwayne Johnson said
you know he was the hard hard thing to
understand or accept right now cuz he
was kind of bigger than life and you
feel like people like that are
invincible you know you look at people
like I looked at my father like that
maybe you didn't know no recently you're
lost your dad yes but now I just really
uh it and I it got me and it got me down
about you know just like why you know
why are you you question things like you
know I don't know about this you only
it's your time it's this is that I don't
know if I I just think this life is what
it is and it's you know you're passed
through it's a gift to be here and you
just don't know well I mean when you
want I don't know yeah I know when you
when you when you think of people like
that I guess one way to help get through
the questions of why is remembering the
good times ride and remembering you know
things of like like him Thor during an
armed robbery in 2016 in Florida and and
and and doing the things that delighted
people as well as well as living life
the way that he did what do you mean he
picked you up to relieve you of vertigo
Nick what happened
I had vertigo one time which was
terrible you know very it's never had it
it's awful you're nauseous you dizzy and
I had it for like a week and went to a
doctor one time and goes oh you got
vertigo and I was like yeah yeah it goes
well I can help you you know he's a head
doctor laying at the end and lean on the
cable and he turned me old but he goes
this close rise and there's a way to do
it late will you turn the guy over on a
table for like 30 seconds 40 and it's
these little particles or something that
they can kind of go back in your head I
mean I don't understand that I'm not a
head doctor right but it helped you know
and gotta close your eyes and so we were
shooting this thing boy school for boys
this little speck pilot over here at
Crespi Encino and he was playing a
teacher we had some funny scenes
together so I was getting a touch of it
and I go outside Chris being it chad is
out there with me and they said hey shad
I got I'm gonna lay on the table turn me
over because he's big guy you know I
said turn me over and you know maybe you
could cure this this this vertical is
coming on so come here come here come
here you put his hands between my crotch
picked me up I didn't expect it I got
you filmed it would have been fantastic
people would have been dying laughing he
picked me up between my collage you know
like like a twig you know just imagine
you only what and turn me over like in a
sudden movement upside down in such a
you know vulnerable position you got it
said he turned me so quick and then I
was a whoa my whole head went you know
got raped and I was like he cured cured
me it was coming on I said well whatever
you did she had you know you turned me
quickly violently it was a violent move
but a beautiful move and we try to
recreate a winner on the podcast what
happens pawnee he's a very funny guy
very funny guy he was always talking
about how big he was and it was
hilarious cuz I'd be like I know you big
you don't got to keep telling me how big
you are you know I was I was
I'd love to like feel and touch him you
know I like I like big guys you know I
like to you know I'm not good yeah Prudy
that way you know it's funny that way
whatever but is gonna get kicked out
like you're not squeezing my stuff come
in come in big you know a big lug and
but you know heart of gold you know a
deep thinker smart guy and like I said
was developing this terrific wrestling
pilot and you know I'm glad that he gave
me a chance
he's just just to pay a little tribute
to my friend because I know it's uh it's
a hard time for his family and we all
gotta try to be there for his wife and
his son who I can't even I can't imagine
that I can't imagine either I can't
imagine what he's going through ten
years old and I'm ten years old yeah I
know it's just you know this life who
can explain it I don't know how you got
here I don't know how I got here well we
got here somehow we had parents you know
how they got you think about it and you
know like Wow
and then you know one day it's gonna go
on without me you know like you do you
think like you know the whole world is
about you know but this was a guy that
that loved people that thought about
people and like you say you stopped the
robbery he helped friends he cured my
vertigo whatever he made your left he
was always happy he was always up and
I'm like I wish I could be more like
that you know and and have that kind of
courage he really did I mean he was that
guy that had that I mean I think there
were some times there were special
people in life that have certain gifts
you know they touch you in a way that
you go that guy you know wow I wish I
could be more like that guy you know so
I know it's it's it's it's tough no you
eat every time I think about him I get
like like old man did this this doesn't
feel real
no I know and what is I know I know
exactly I know Nick and it's in these
times obviously we make you make you
wonder what is but I know when you
reached out and you're like hey would
you want to say some words about him I'm
like why you you know and you do it and
you did a great job Nick and I thank you
this is not my forte I'm not no somebody
gets updated speeches about people
knowing I can talk you know you want to
talk about baseball movies I could talk
to the morning you know I mean I could
talk to the sunrise right but when it
comes to like you know putting being you
know eloquent or being you know very you
know cohesive what my word doesn't
matter I probably would call on somebody
like my brother who's more of a brain
person right you know right I got a
brain but it works in a different way
by the way you're gonna see by the way
you're gonna see some do the right
things stuff coming up very soon on the
last dance - you'll see some of the
stuff speaking of your brother oh wow I
can't wait oh yeah do they touch on the
baseball stuff - and oh yes
Oh big-time oh yeah absolutely yeah
you'll see you'll see him at the
Birmingham Barons but I'm into it you
got it ain't Nick you take care of
yourself be well you and your family
we'll catch up right back at you I love
breaking bread with Nick des terreaux is
his podcast and we'll get Nick back on
when baseball gets back on
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here